vous êtes monsieur distinguer aimable
courtois cela se voit lorsque vous êtes
en contact on le dit et vous le croyez
mais il ya en vous un personnage tout
prêt à donner à démentir cette flatteuse
réputation
le chauffeur
[Musique]
à peine assis au volant regardez vous
vous l'êtes déjà plus le même
vous démarrez sans vous occuper des
autres et l'autre vous l'envoyer dans le
décor vous aviez tort vous le savez
alors vous êtes grossier
[Musique]
vous croyez trop facilement que la route
vous appartient et que toutes les places
de stationnement sont de bonnes prises
en accaparant sans plus de ménagement
cette place ou à un autre se ranger vous
avez agi comme un mal appris et amal a
pris satisfait ce qui est dit de votre
côté prétend vous montrer par trop
d'insouciance
les rues ne sont pas faites à l'usagé
exclusif des amateurs de mots croisés
vous êtes dans votre droit cette fois
mais la voiture a respecté les clous
pourquoi les grands mots la route certes
est à chacun mais elle est de ce fait à
tout le monde aussi ne la prenez pas
pour un salon de beauté
alors ne croyez vous pas que pour les
fêtes de pâques
chacun pourrait y mettre du sien ce
serait tellement mieux
[Musique]